das hier ist kein normales Essen perfekt
angerichtet und bis ins Detail
ausgeklügelt aber die Frage ist wie
entsteht ein Menü in der
Sterneküche ich hatte das große Glück
schon häufiger in sterneestaurants Essen
zu dürfen und jedes Mal aufs Neue werde
ich überrascht scheinbar sind der
Kreativität dem Handwerk und einfach
allem in der Sterneküche keine Grenzen
gesetzt oftmals bietet sich auf dem
Teller ein Bild da was wunderschönes
aber mindestens genauso schwer zu
verstehen wir schauen heute ein bisschen
hinter die Kulissen und sehen Maximilian
Lorenz dabei zu wie sich seine Gerichte
zusammensetzen so max willkommen zu
deinem ersten Gang ja wir haben ein
selbstgemachten Wildschweinschinken der
noch nicht ganz durchgetrocknet ist weil
wir ein bisschen creamiger haben wollten
dazu selbstingelegte Nüsse quasi
fermentiert abgerundet wird es mit
Sellerie gewechseln sowohl
stauensellerie als auch Knolle und dazu
noch ein bisschen Sandorn für dich als
altes norddeutsches Kind genau das
richtige deswegen sag was du denkst und
ich wünsche dir guten Appetit dabei wow
vielen lieben Dank danke schön
klassischer Donnerstag 14 Uhr ich sitze
hier am chefstable und habe vom
legendären sternkoch Maximilian Lorenz
hier eine kleine vorschweise serviert
bekommen also optisch wunderschön man
sieht förmlich dass das mit der Pinzette
angerichtet wurde und darum sind noch so
kleine Streußel nenne ich es jetzt
einfach mal das könnte man fast mit der
Hand nehmen aber wir sind hier in dem
sternestaurant das heißt nehmen uns hier
einmal das Besteck und arbeiten uns rein
oh ich dachte das sei so ein Cracker das
sah fast aus wie ein Cracker ist aber
total weich quasi die Basis also dann
auf
euch wir haben wirklich eine süße die
sich überhaupt nicht verstecken will
gleichzeitig so ein leichter Crunch von
den Nüssen die dadurch dass sie
eingelegt sind aber trotzdem so ein
bisschen weicher zu kauen werden das ist
schon fast so eine süße die ein bisschen
süchtig macht und dankeön habe ich schön
gesagt dr ist geschlossene Gesellschaft
eine Vorspeise die Lust auf mehr macht
man hat echt das Gefühl man wird auf
eine Reise eingestimmt und die nimmt
jetzt ihren Lauf
deshalb ich liebe mein Job weiter geht's
mit dem zweiten Gang ich sehe schon
wieder den Chef wow so max ich hoffe du
siehst nicht ganz so viel Rot bei dem
Gang haben wir uns einfach eine Sache
mal hinterfragt können wir eigentlich
vegan kochen es war etwas was wir nie
wollten aber unterschwellig passiert ist
wir haben keine tierischen Produkte
verarbeitet die Idee ist hier bei dem
Gang etwas zu zeigen was eigentlich gar
nicht harmoniert Bitternis haben eine
relativ süßliche Paprika Creme eine
süßliche rote wete Creme gemacht um
einfach ein pondon dazu zetzen und die
Röllchen sind von der gegrillten Roten
Bete die wir mit dem Rot betelack
überzogen haben also du hast eben gerade
gesagt der erste Gang stand für dich
sehr in der süße% wo du gesagt hast so
das macht so Suchtcharakter du willst
einfach mehr essen jetzt setzen wir den
Dämpfer jetzt kommt Bitternis dagegen
ich wünsche dir ganz viel Spaß enjoy the
ride danke schön gerne danke schön wow
also optisch muss ich sagen gefällt der
mir noch mal eine Ecke besser ich finde
auf dem weißen Teller so auch dass man
so mit vielen Platz arbeitet der einfach
nicht genutzt wird das ist auch sehr
sehr kunstvoll man will das gar nicht
essen so schön ist es ich geh einfach
mal hier rein probieren
wir
boah ich habe mit
mehr einfacher bitterheit gerechnet aber
das ist total Komplex also so diese
Traube die so ein bisschen platzt im
Mund Paprika das ist auch eine volle
Bandbreite die man hier bekommt auf eine
Art und Weise auch irgendwie fruchtig
aber trotzdem total es ist wirklich ein
richtiger Gegenpol zu dem ersten Gang
den wir hatten wow richtig richtig
lecker so max wow dein nächstes Gericht
ist quasi unser gaumenkino unsere Idee
war eigentlich da warten wir noch ein
bisschen auf die Druckerei weil du ja
quasi outn und relativ exklusiv ist eine
Banderole drum zu machen und dann drauf
zu Schreiben ratatoui im Rausch der
Sterne Madame morelie und der Duft von
Curry einfach kulinarische Filme die
sich an Essen erinnern und dann halt
sowas zu setzen wie so ein # gaumkino
geschmackshöhepunkt also alles wo du
sagst so hier passiert was und da haben
wir auch angefangen den Mais
aufzugreifen wir haben einmal ganz
klassischen Popcorn gemacht ein bisschen
salzig eine maisceme haben dann mit
unreifen zwetschchen gearbeitet die wir
gerade Höchstzeit haben du kennst
meistens wird da ja ein zwätschchen tben
Ja und
udcker undimzcker ja und wir wollten
einfach zeigen was eine unreife
Zwetschke kann verschiedene Texturen
verschiedene garethoden und ich sag
einfach gar nicht so viel bisschen Grün
kann ist auch noch mit drin aber das
einfach nur so als texturgeber geh mit
dem Löffel rein und dann schauen was mit
dir passiert ich liebe solche Gerichte
die so vielschichtig sind wo man sich
quasi erstmal einarbeiten muss und dann
mit jedem weiteren Löffel auch noch was
neues entdeckt so innerhalb von einem
Gang aber ich gehe erstmal hier oben
bisschen vom Schaum bisschen von Popcorn
und probiere das
ganze boah das ist dieses wo man sich
reinlegen kann dieser
Schaum weiß nicht wie es euch geht ich
habe auch schon wieder vergessen was ist
ist so herzhaft so intensiv irgendwie so
buttrig sahnig dazu der Crunch von dem
grünkm das weiche
Popcorn mal etwas sehr sterernestaurant
untypisches machen er das probiere ja
okay weil du checkst gar nicht wie das
schmeckt geh mal komplett rein das fühlt
sich so so traumhaft an von allem
etwas m ich glaube erst mit der zetsch
gemacht richtig Sinn wow das erinnert
mich gerade unormal an meine Oma diese
zetch ja die hat immer quetscheekre
gebacken so heißt das auf hässisch boah
und wir hatten auch einen einen zetschen
Baum im Garten stehen wo ich auch durch
aus mal dran genascht habe als sie noch
nicht ganz reif waren deshalb erinnert
mich das gerade total daran ist zu
dieser herzhaft Creme zu dem herzhaften
Schaum so ein geiler frischer Gegenpart
ich finde es echt wild weil das sind das
ist ja so ein Stück weit das wo für
Maximilian Loran steht das sind alles
Deutsche Zutaten das ist auch so etwas
was man sich so niemals im Leben zu
Hause so kochen würde so sowas gibt es
nur in der
Sternegastronomie so max du bist ein
relativ heißer Typ bringe ich dir was
kaltes dagegen für Dich unsere Zitronen
Buttermilch Erfrischung ein bisschen
Buttermilch bisschen Zitrone bisschen
Blüten enjoy the R lehn dich zurück
genieß es denk einfach gar nicht nach
stell dir vor du bist gerade irgendwie
so mit den Füßen im Wasser ein malfi
Küste die Sonne Küst so gerade so aufs
brusthaupthaar ein bisschen bisschen
Hintergrundmusik so eine leichte Brise
geht vorbei nimm es in die Hand lehn
dich zurück viel Spaß das ist wirklich
das was ich jetzt gerade brauche nach
diesen ersten gangngen was einfaches ich
sehe schon Buttermilch Zitroneneis das
kann nur gut sein probieren wir mal
boah im Moment wo man das in den Mund
nimmt zerfließt es einfach oben drauf
diese Zitronenschalen die Fäden haben
ein schönen Biss geben bisschen Textur
dazu das ist erfrischend das ist vor
allem wirklich schön einfach Frage ist
bist du jetzt mit den Füßen im
Wasser ich spürre gerade schon auf
meinem brusthaupthar die die Sonne
kitzeln ja es ist einfach geil ich liebe
auch Buttermilch Zitroneneis und das ist
ein richtig richtig gutes mit ein zwei
Twists durch die Schalen durch diese
Cremes die noch oben drauf sind es ist
einfach lecker wow
BAM Philips vegu aus Deutschland oft
denken Leute mal ist rein asiatisches
Produkt aber es ist die Region kurbe wo
es herkommt vegu die Rasse wir haben es
wirklich nur von einer Seite angegrillt
es ist im Kern komplett roh dann haben
wir ein Produkt gefunden was so ein
bisschen für unsere DNA steht
Nachhaltigkeit arbeiten und wir haben
die Leber vom ver genommen abgerundet
wird das mit so einer kleinen
pilzvariation wir haben eine Krause
Glucke wir haben frittierte buchenpilz
wir haben eine kleine Pilzcreme
Blumenkohl haben wir gemacht und nachher
gibt es ein Schlüssel das ist die
vinigret oder auch besser bekannt so als
J mit Einlage wir haben einfach die Vio
Abschnitte vom Rücken runterkochen
lassen mit Rotwein ein bisschen Honig
ein bisschen dunklem Essig haben tapioca
einfach als Bindung reingegeben und
champignonwürfel angeschwitzt mit da
rein und diese Soße ist nachher
eigentlich so ich sag's mal der Game
changer ja viel Spaß danke schön wow
Leute ich bin zum einen sowas von bereit
weil gerade noch dieser Refresher wirkt
also ich habe das Gefühl so ich bin
ready für alles was kommt W ne wie soll
W wohl schmecken ich probiere direkt mal
Bo das ist tatsächlich wirklich nur auf
der Haut ang grht unten ist es sogar
gänzlich roh also großes Vertrauen und
natürlich wie es im sternrestaurant sein
soll ein sehr sehr guter Einkauf zu so
ein Pilz und ein bisschen was von dieser
Vinaigrette boah die ist wirklich schön
kräftig das ist ein hundertprozentiger
Hauptgang also klar als Hauptgang zu
erkennen nicht irgendwie so oh war der
Hauptgang schon nee das ist größere
Portion kräftiges umami eine
Geschmackskomponente die wir auch noch
gar nicht hatten
bisher ne wir von allem anderen noch mal
ein bisschen was wir haben wirklich so
spannende Zutaten hier auch dabei ich
will gar nicht wissen wie lange diese
einzelnen Komponenten auch so
verarbeitet wurden oder was mit denen
gemacht wurde dass sie jetzt auch da
liegen ich meine jetzt gerade im
anrichten hat man gesehen jedes einzelne
wurde einfach dazuelegt und so aber was
wurde mit diesem Blumenkohl vorher
gemacht was wurde mit diesem Pilz vorher
gemacht damit er jetzt so auf der Zunge
explodiert wie jetzt bei dir weißt du mm
bin jetzt auch sehr gespannt auf die
vegu Leber auf jeden Fall eine ganz
andere Charakteristik schon wenn man die
Gabel reinsticht als
äh gerade bei dem
Rücken das ist wirklich was ganz
besonderes ne krass also es hat so diese
dichte und Cremigkeit keine wie auch so
vorgr so so gänsestoffleber aber es ist
wirklich überhaupt nicht bitter es ist
speziell muss ich sagen aber ich finde
es passt auch wie Faust aufs Auge hier
in das Konzept von Max Lorenz weil auch
Leber ist auch so ein so urdeutsch so
also das das passt irgendwie einfach
alles so max last but not least der du
denkst jetzt wahrscheinlich Schokolade
Himbeere alles falsch Teil meiner
Familie kommt aus Süddeutschland und
dort gibt super Mirabellen und ich liebe
Mirabellen die Aprikosen des Deutschen
haben wir in verschiedenen Texturen
dargeboten du wirst vielleicht beim sor
auch so ein bisschen zurückversetzt
setzen an an den fresh Maker aber der
Knaller ist hier eigentlich die süß
Kartoffel du denkst jetzt an
Süßkartoffel dieses gekaufte Produkt
Pommes sükartoffel Pommes genau oder
oder einfach an die süß Kartoffel an mal
wir haben süß Kartoffel
Anführungszeichen gesetzt denn was kaum
einer weiß wenn man Kartoffel
verarbeitet z.B richtig schlecht sie mal
einfriert so
Kartoffelpüree dann fängt an der Stärke
Gehalt der Kartoffel zu brechen es
entsteht Zucker das sieht nicht schön
aus aber der Saft ist knatschsüß so
kannst aus etwas salzigen etwas süßen
machen deswegen haben wir unsere
Süßkartoffel Anführungszeichen gesetzt
nicht nur süß kartoffelfarbeit sondern
auch ganz normale herkömmliche
vorwiegend festkochende Kartoffel und
haben sie mit ein zwei triggern so
geändert dass aus einer ich nenne es mal
brakkartoffel zu schweinshaachse auf
einmal ein genialer dessertpart wird das
sieht wirklich gut aus also ich freue
mich auch jetzt noch mal auf dem Dessert
weil das war schon gerade sehr herzhaft
jetzt noch mal auf einer süßen Note zu
enden kann ich kan ich mir sehr gut
vorstellen süßkartoffelchips
Süßkartoffel Mirabelle es sieht einfach
gut aus ne so diese verschiedenen gelb
Orang Töne ich will direkt das Eis
probieren bevor es mir komplett
wegschmilzt erinnert mich wirklich auf
eine Art und Weise an das Buttermilch
Zitroneneis was wir zwischendurch hatten
sehr lecker Mirabelle Note die man nicht
direkt zuordnen kann weil man es einfach
so selten ist aber wächst es hier
einfach an den Bäumen gehen wir
rein
also auch hier verständliches trotzdem
kreatives Dessert wieder mit Komponenten
aus der deutschen Küche und schmeckt so
als keine Ahnung schmeckt einfach
gut dadurch dass wir die Anrichtung
beobachten konnten diese etwas
ausführlicheren Erklärungen bekommen
haben kann ich auf jeden Fall besser
verstehen wie so ein Sternerestaurant
sein Menü konzipiert nichtsdestotrotz
bin ich einfach beeindruckt das ist
crazy die Kreativität die handwerkliche
Klasse einfach geil das wird auf jeden
Fall nicht alt und ich hoffe meine
Videos auch nicht deshalb sehen wir uns
beim nächsten wieder bis dahin macht's
gut ciao
ciao